c'est à l'espace raid l'est du bas de la
rivière que s'est déroulée la formation
sst sauveteur secouriste du travail pour
les agents du conseil général cette
formation initiale prépare le sauveteur
secouriste du travail à intervenir
rapidement et efficacement lors d'une
situation d'accident du travail dans
l'établissement
son but acquérir les connaissances pour
apporter les premiers soins et les
conduites à tenir en attendant l'arrivée
des secours alors de cette formation
qu'est ce qu'on apprend nos collègues de
fait la protection déjà soi même comment
écarter les badauds comment examiné la
victime pour savoir qu'est ce qui se
passe
donner le message dalet a acquis on va
appeler le 15 le 17 le 18 ou bien le 112
est aussi apprendre collègues comment
arrêter un saignement et quand je parle
de ces aimants il ya le serment qui
commence au niveau de la tête jusqu'aux
pieds à la tête la bouche le nez
l'oreille thorax l'abdomen membres
inférieurs même supérieur sectionnement
d'un homme
après le sermon ne collecte pas à
prendre en cas d'étouffement par ce
conte
mange aux séries dans le service dans la
comptine en cas d'étouffement d'un
adulte de nourrissons d'un enfant
comment faire pour désobstruer la voix
aussi après l'étouffement bas il ya la
réanimation cardio pulmonaire comment
savoir quand est ce qu'on va perdre la
réelle nature corderie moderne mais tout
simplement quand on a fait l'examen de
la victime et à la fin je détecte que la
personne est inconsciente mais qui ne
respire pas là je dois vérifier tout de
suite le 15 après le 15
on va commencer faire le manoeuvre massé
souffler pour réanimer la personne jusqu
à ce qu arrive on va apprendre collègues
aussi messi comment reconnaître
quelqu'un qui se plaint d'un malaise
parce que c'est très important le
malaise on ne plaisante pas là dessus il
ya des signes pour nous à notre niveau
valeur sûre agitation
anomalies de la parole difficultés à
parler la personne à froid
par un résident d'un côté
douleurs au thorax acs a fait très mal
d'où le à l'abdomen pour nous à notre
niveau c'est un type de malaise alors il
faut savoir dans quelles conditions
qu'on met la personne sont en position
semi assise soit allongée mais aussi on
va lui poser des questions voilà un
petit peu ce qu'on fait dans cette
formation sauveteur secouriste aval
c'est une formation pratique de
commencement jusqu'à la fin il ya
beaucoup de pratique
protection examiné secourir fait à l'été
le plus rapide possible voilà ce qu'on
doit faire une formation jugée utile et
nécessaire par les participants en
enseignements précieux en cas
d'accidents au travail mais également
dans la vie de tous les jours
l'information est très importante au
milieu d'eux
collectivités sur son public au niveau
je travaille donc un cas de besoin c'est
un collègue ferme à l'aise ce couple se
brûle donc on sera toujours là pour
apporter une assistance médicale de
premiers secours avant que les pompiers
ou autres autres collègues dans le
milieu de prévention arrive donc c'est
une formation très importante qui est
qui pour moi très bénéfique aussi de mon
côté que ça doit le public au sein de ma
famille en cas de nécessité cl il ya un
problème dont vous serez là
on va pas des premiers secours dans que
les pompiers arrivent ou autre cette
formation est utile autant professeur
professionnellement que personnellement
parce que ben en tant qu'animateur je
fréquente souvent un public que souad
adultes seniors enfants j'ai des
activités au quotidien avec eux donc si
jamais y arriver à pépins au moins moi
je sais faire gestes de premiers secours
après personnellement forcément dans la
vie de tous les jours si on a tout le
monde a une famille il peut arriver
n'importe où n'importe quoi n'importe
quel moment donc c'est déjà bien de
savoir si j'ai cela sans âme sans
s'affoler
en attendant les arrivées l'arrivée des
secours
la validation de la formation est faite
après une évaluation continue des
stagiaires un certificat sst l'aurait
ensuite délivré